[Música]
en directo américa de france 24
continuamos dando seguimiento a lo que
ocurre en reino unido tras la muerte de
la reina isabel segunda hemos tratado
varios puntos y hoy vamos a hablar de
los momentos más difíciles que ha tenido
que sortear la corona británica entre
críticas y también escándalos para ello
salgamos entonces a jonathan iglesias
sancho el historiador experto en realeza
jonathan gracias por estar con nosotros
esta mañana de viernes ya en directo
américa de franz schubert de 24 le
pregunto cuáles han sido los momentos
más difíciles que ha tenido que vivir la
corona británica
bueno la corona británica bueno ante
todo muchas gracias y buenas tardes aquí
desde españa la corona británica está
enfrentado a muchos momentos complicados
a muchos momentos difíciles hay que
empezar por ejemplo hablando de él el
propio proceso de descolonización no de
las colonias
que habían áfrica o que había en américa
y el ansia por parte del reino unido y
luego de una forma más interna pues todo
este proceso que hubo cole dice
actualmente todo lo que ha ocurrido con
el príncipe harry y megan entonces ha
habido muchos momentos tanto a nivel
político en los cuales la familia real
no tenía un efecto
propio porque no nos involucraban pero
luego sí es verdad que ha habido unos
escándalos personales que han afectado
evidentemente a la familia y al país
entero por supuesto claro jonathan
podemos entonces en estos escándalos que
a pues se ha picado no a la corona
británica primero las acusaciones estas
de imperialismo
también de la commonwealth algunos que
ya no quieren pertenecer algunos que
siguen con el resentimiento de ser
colonizados o por los británicos o como
lleva a esto la realeza británica
bueno aquí hay que hacer digamos una
división
isabel segunda carlos tercero ahora
mismo no tiene un poder político en
reino unido por lo tanto ellos en toda
esta política de descolonización que
empezó ya con el padre de saber segunda
ellos no intervienen isabel segunda no
tomó ninguna decisión política a la hora
de descolonizar
bueno por las distintas colonias que
había allí eso fue una decisión
completamente del gobierno de turno ella
pues tuvo que aceptar ya no se puede
implicar en política es cierto también
que y saber según ha sido un icono a
todo toda la monarquía británica ha
girado en torno a la figura de saber
segundo por lo tanto eso hace que
también sean a diana de las críticas
porque es la única figura representativa
real que hay no son los distintos
primeros ministros o primeras ministras
que ha habido sino que ha sido bella
entonces es normal que las críticas que
hayan sobre ella
pero sí que haya sabido más o menos ella
capear un poco todos los problemas
sí que es verdad que existe todavía ese
aire del sentimiento por parte de las
antiguas colonias siga habiendo colonias
todavía los llaman a
alguien por ejemplo en sudamérica tuvo
que ser traumático todo el proceso de la
marina argentina aquí en europa también
tenemos todavía pues gibraltar hay
muchas todavía pero yo creo que la
crítica siempre es buena se hace una
crítica positiva
entonces todos esos países miembros de
la commonwealth que quieren
dejar de tener una jefa de estado en
este caso era un jefe de estado
monárquico como como carlos tercero
bueno lo podemos hacer por supuesto pero
no salen de la commonwealth es decir una
cosa es que ellos esas antiguas colonias
hayan decidido quedarse como como
repúblicas que por supuesto se dan en su
poder de hacerlo pero siguen dentro del
marco de la commonwealth cuyo máximo
líder honorífico en este caso en este
caso es carlos tercero
jonathan digamos que eso desde afuera
para adentro pero dentro de la casa real
británica estuvimos todos presentes en
este uno estando los más recientes y fue
el del éxito estas acusaciones después
de racismo de un tipo también de presión
que sufrían los duques estos excesos por
parte pues de la reina isabel segunda y
como de su entorno en las preocupaciones
también que habían de que si su hijo iba
a ser un poco oscuro el color de piel y
pues todo esto que no no fue visto con
los mejores ojos por la reinicia de
segunda recordemos también que los tres
ex renunciaron a todos pues todos sus
atributos atributos reales como esto
también impactó la figura de la reina
isabel segunda y la monarquía
bueno es que claro el tema este del
príncipe harry 6 de mexicano es un tema
complicado es un tema muy complicado
porque yo creo que la situación se les
ha ido un poco de las manos ambas para
tanto para con una británica como al
matrimonio de milán y harry
megan es una chica que viene de un
digamos de un mundo completamente
distinto a la realeza
yo no creo que hubiera habido de verdad
un racismo real por parte de isabel
segundo por parte definitiva del mundo
yo no creo que haya habido un racismo
real había cierta preocupación porque
tenía de un ambiente completamente
distinto pero sí que entender en cuenta
que se realizó el matrimonio y el
matrimonio se realizó es porque saber
segunda dio ese consentimiento si no ese
matrimonio se hubiera realizado yo sí
creo que megan tal vez
[Música]
vio las cosas de una forma que no supo
gestionar y digamos eso se se sale de
madre esta gente cuando los miembros de
la realeza isabel segundo a felipe de
edimburgo están más que acostumbrados a
tratar con líderes de otro tipo de
etnias por ejemplo no se ha visto un
montón de veces hay saber segunda
tratando de tú a tú casi como iguales a
presidentes de las repúblicas africana
entonces un racismo real yo no creo por
parte ojo por parte de la familia
extinto es por parte de la propia
digamos estructura de la corona eso es
otra cosa pero por parte de la monarquía
por parte de isabel segunda felipe de
edimburgo y bueno los príncipes y tal yo
no creo que haya un racismo real yo creo
que se les ha escapado de las manos a
los dos un poco yo creo que ya para ir
finalizando nuestra conversación es
jonathan hablemos de otro escándalo
también y todo lo que tiene que ver con
las salpicaduras de el príncipe andrés
en no involucrado en un caso de abuso
sexual cuando una persona una mujer era
menor de edad hace ya varios años
recordemos que él pues al final el trato
y pago puede ser una compensación a esta
víctima pero nos habló más del caso la
reina isabel pues evidentemente apoyo
digamos del número de su hijo sin
embargo también se le retiraron todos
sus subtítulos sus títulos reales lo
vimos también en el funeral de la reina
isabel segunda vestido prácticamente de
civil solamente con algunas medallas de
lo que sigue en el ejército pero no
mucho más como sus otros hermanos
entonces también como esto
salpicó y digamos impacto en la corona
bueno eso s que verlo siempre como en
una familia normal es decir como le
puede sentar a una abuela oa una madre
en este caso que su hijo esté implicado
en un asunto tan feo y tan escabroso
como este del príncipe andrés
evidentemente hay saber segunda y sólo
tuvo que sentar muy mal si tuvo que
sentar muy mal y ella hizo lo propio
como reina es decir quitar los honores y
apartarlo un poco de la figura pública
de príncipe aunque como familia es decir
como hijo de la difunta acude por
supuesto a la ceremonia de todo lo que
tenga que ver con entidades madre pero
evidentemente esto puede ser un
escándalo tremendo dentro y ya me lo
tuvo que sentar nada bien pero nada bien
por eso he apartado andrés fue
completamente apartado también hay que
tener en cuenta
que todo esto de que ahora ya no se
habla tanto o que ahora ya se ha
apartado un poco todo esto no creo yo
que sea tanto por presiones de la corona
sino por parte del propio sistema el
propio sistema en defensa de la corona
hace que todo esto un poco se se quede
quieto sobre todo ahora mismo que está
en la protagonista indiscutible es
isabel segunda
pero no la casa real
ellos han hecho lo que han tenido que
hacer que es apartar a andrés de todo y
les ha tenido que ser tremendamente
aunque no sigan teniendo dentro de la
familia como hermanos